welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber a new trial is underway
in New Hampshire that is the stuff of
nightmares a man is accused of breaking
into the home of an only Fan's model and
taking video of her while she slept
police say Mauricio Guerrero drove from
Pennsylvania to New Hampshire to the
home where a woman known as Rachel lived
with her mother he allegedly broke into
the house and took videos of the victim
as she slept naked it's believed
Guerrero even spent time in her attic
because she found food headphones and
cups filled with urine when she searched
up there he also allegedly put a
tracking device on her possessions
Rachel who shares content on the site
only fans says that she gave Guerrero
her previous address so that he could
send her gifts like a new television she
said she had no intention of meeting him
in person despite that the two did meet
for at least one consensual sexual
encounter before Guerrero allegedly
broke into her home multiple times on
Wednesday the prosecution and defense
gave their opening statements take a
listen
this to-do list of his plans for when he
was there and demonstrates that he is on
a mission and that list that to-do list
is found
it has things like go to her house then
put a tracker on her car lock the
courthouse find her room and her stuff
get a key copy put microphones and stuff
to hear her log into her phone hopefully
make sure to be very careful and
sneakable around your home
remember get her phone and open it
Unblock Me on everything
it also details our son's name his date
of birth a description of where her two
friends live that she drives a white
Jeep it lists her license plate and the
name and number of Nate Wilson okay
so over the next two days from that
Monday so early Wednesday morning when
he's arrested he Endeavors to complete
this list
he's like okay great and they have the
information they have a date
no he stays there he stays for a couple
hours in her home she lives in the door
all the time and he stays there and then
he came to conceptual activities the new
course
and then you know he
needs some money and he needs some gifts
he also and this is interesting too
because you know most people who are
contact providers don't usually give
their addresses to their clients
and she does that so he can have stuff
delivered through her house but she's
all for and remember she's really in
position control here she's older she's
in the business she's young naive
because he's a dumb person reacts done
stupidly so he's in love She's led him
off and you know to say that she's
sending mixed messages which went with
one of the ways she describes this she's
interviewed as well and one of the way
she describes as well again I guess I
was sitting in mixed messages blessed
are so wildly protest we understand
she also describes her behavior is
beating him on and messing with his head
all right let's bring in our co-hosts
and legal analyst defense attorney Brian
buckmeyer former trial Attorney Terry
Austin Brian what do you make of
Guerrero's defense that she wanted to be
filmed could we hear that in their
opening statements I thought it was
interesting at first I was like I I
don't know if this is really going to
fly you hear the prosecution's case
there where Guerrero knows so much about
this woman these odd details I'm not
even sure if most couples know these
things about them unless they're
stalking the other person but the
defense's argument of you don't
typically give out your address uh even
your own comments make it suggest that
you think that you may have been leading
him on it might hold more water than I
initially thought I think it's a
creative argument to say that your
client is quote unquote dumb but if it
works it works is he going to take the
stand though to kind of prove that to us
or is it just the facts I don't know but
so far it's something if it works that's
the question if it works so Brian
mentioned the word stalking which I
think is interesting Terry because why
is Mr Guerrero facing these charges of
residential burglary instead of
something like stalking well they could
have charged the stocking because it
just takes two or more actions that put
someone in fear and clearly he he's in
her house and he was there multiple
times and she was definitely in fear but
they did the burglary because they have
evidence that he broke into that house
they have the evidence that there was
closing there they knew that he was
living there so that's why I think they
focused on that the stalking might be a
little more difficult because of this
claim that they connected with each
other and so perhaps he wasn't
technically like stalking her so I think
they picked the easiest one to try to
convince this jury what a disturbing
case imagine finding this out if you're
the victim oh my goodness now all right
let's switch gears now to Nevada we're a
former Dances with Wolves actor it was
indicted on sexual abuse charges now
wants the state supreme court to throw
out the case Nathan chasing horse is
facing 18 felonies prosecutors accused
chasing horse of using his position as a
Native American leader to create a cult
and convince victims that their
ancestors wanted to have sex with him
according to new court documents chasing
horse his attorneys say that prosecutors
provided information about alleged
Grooming by the former actor but that's
not an element of sexual assault under
the law instead they say the information
was prejudicial and it led the grand
jury to file the charges chasing horse
was originally scheduled to go to trial
on May 1st but a stay was issued while
his legal team filed the appeal to the
state supreme court you've got our hands
on some new video of the so-called
doomsday Duo Lori vallo day Bell and her
new husband Chad dabell when they were
presented with a court order demanding
that she produced her two missing
children the video from January 25th
2020 shows Laurie and Chad poolside at a
Hawaii Resort where they had gotten
married two of Lori's children J.J valo
and Tyler Ryan had been last seen in
September of 2019. Chad's Wife Tammy
dabell had died suddenly just weeks
before Lori and Chad got married the
documents from Madison County Idaho say
that Lori has five days to safely
present her 16 year old Tyler and
seven-year-old JJ there children when
the men were presented or the men
presented Lori with the paperwork she
really had almost no reaction
sir
you have any questions regarding that
any questions you have any questions for
that
okay
all right have a nice day have a nice
day
all right Lori and Chad are being
charged separately in connection with
the deaths of JJ and Tyler as well as
Chad's Wife Tammy Lori's trial is
wrapping up right now in Boise Idaho the
prosecution wrapped up its case on
Tuesday after calling around at 60
Witnesses the defense then said it did
not believe the state had proven its
case so it rested without presenting any
Witnesses of its own on Wednesday the
attorneys met with the judge to talk
about jury instructions closing
arguments will be held on Thursday when
the jury will get the case prosecutors
made the case that Lori valo and Chad
dabell met at a religious conference and
started an affair the state claims that
they wanted to get rid of anyone
standing in the way of them being
together including Lori's two youngest
children Laurie's estranged husband and
Chad's wife they say the couple used
their bizarre doomsday religious beliefs
to justify quote removing obstacles Lori
faces charges of first-degree murder and
conspiracy despite the media only having
access to the audio from the proceedings
the judge decided the court will live
stream the jury's verdict so you can see
the result of this very high profile
case right here on the long crime
Network as it happens let's break it
down Brian conspiracy to commit murder
for grand theft by deception looking at
the jury instructions do you think the
jury will come back with a quick verdict
Jesse I know the three of us would love
to have a quick verdict we can get in
and out don't have to do the verdict
watch for a long time but I think we are
in for a long jury deliberation because
I look at the conspiracy charges
especially what the model during
instructions are going to be meaning
what they use as a template and what
likely they're arguing about and we'll
share with the jurors is this idea that
they can establish conspiracy by simply
showing the manner is sufficient that
both parties understood the agreement
they don't need to show a direct
agreement or a text message or something
like that and they can also imply it by
the conduct of the defendant so like you
showed there maybe her lying on the
beach in Hawaii where her children are
dead and the text message between them
implies their conduct but I think it's
very subjective and will take a lot for
this jury to come together and say no
this is a conspiracy or this is not so
Terry you've been following the trial
very closely what do you expect to hear
in the closing arguments well I
definitely think that the prosecution is
going to focus first on JJ and Tyler
because that's the easier case the case
against Tammy is a little bit more
difficult but I think for JJ and tally
they're going to talk about the
conversations that Lori had with family
and with friends about the fact that her
children were dark and that they were
zombies and even a conversation about
death and they're going to focus on her
financial interest in their social
services and Social Security benefits so
I think that that's how they're going to
tie that all together Tammy's going to
be a little bit harder because there is
no direct evidence and they're going to
have to show that there were
conversations between Chad and Lori on
the date that Tammy died and that she
bought the ring before Tammy died and
that she went to Hawaii last thing I'll
mention as to JJ and Tyler don't forget
there's a piece of hair on the duct tape
for JJ so I think that's important that
is a strong piece of forensic evidence
in the circumstantial evidence case
we'll see how it wraps up but I'll tell
you what how about a little bit of a
lighter story right well police in
Oklahoma got a report of someone calling
for help and they quickly responded to a
rural area the two officers could hear
the yells in the distance but they
quickly discovered that the Damsel in
Distress wasn't even human
how's it going
[Applause]
oh yes it is
now the farmer on the property said that
that goat had gotten separated from a
friend and wasn't very happy about it I
make the same sound when I don't see
Brian buckmeyer a lot of you don't know
that